mark zuckerberg says in five years
facebook will not be the social media
company as we know it it'll be a
metaverse company now that term was
invented back in 1992 in the novel snow
crash by neil stevenson it refers to a
virtual universe beyond our everyday
reality we spoke to mark zuckerberg
exclusively that's the real mark
zuckerberg about the company's first big
step into the metaverse that is being
released today and we have to say it's
pretty amazing
let's talk about metaverse
because you know
for most people it's a term that they're
not familiar with and if they are
familiar with it they don't really know
what it means it reminds me when we
first heard about the internet what is
it www what how does that work
you know i don't want to be a meme years
from now where we're talking about
metaverse how do you see the metaverse
so i think of the the metaverse as
the next
generation of the internet so you can
kind of think about it as
instead of
being an internet
that we look at it's an internet that we
are a part of or that we can be inside
of think films like ready player one
where the idea of a metaverse went by a
different name
except for eating sleeping and bathroom
breaks whatever people want to do they
do it in the oasis
i always wanted to help build this kind
of immersive
system that you could be in with your
friends and feel like you were present
together but go explore you know other
planets or other periods of time or you
know play games together but feel like
you were really in it together
but today you've got a big announcement
drumroll please we like a big
announcement on cbs and we really like
it when we're the only ones that have
that announcement so what's your big
announcement today
so today we're announcing
a new service called
workrooms it's basically a virtual
reality service for collaborating
together and doing work this is going to
be one part of this overall vision that
we've talked about and something that
we've been using internally at facebook
for a while and we really like but it
basically gives you the opportunity to
you know sit around a table with people
and work and brainstorm and whiteboard
ideas for people who can't be there
through virtual reality they can just
video conference ends so you can include
everyone but it's this pretty amazing
experience where
you know you feel like you're really
right there with your colleagues i'm up
for a demonstration let's go workrooms
is used on facebook's oculus quest 2
virtual reality headsets once inside you
can customize your own avatar
mark i'm in
all right welcome oh my god you've got
freckles on your nose i have freckles in
real life too so you know trying to do
the best of having
do you like my glasses i like it in here
your avatar looks great this is my first
virtual
reality interview how about you mine too
my first virtual reality interview too
isn't it good excited to do this with
you isn't it good we can do this
together so how long have you been
working on this were you getting all
zoomed out because i was thinking i was
getting zoomed out were you getting
zoomed out so we actually started
working on this even before covid and
this has been a long-term project um you
know partially because we we
you know just been really optimistic
about virtual reality wait mark this is
so cool wait just stop for a second
because every gesture you make
it's
i can see all your hands your
oh my gosh yeah no this is um you know
one of the things that that makes the
biggest difference to me is i don't know
if you've had this experience on
um on video conferences is basically
you're looking at a grid of faces yeah
and
there's there's no sense of space right
so when you're in when you're really
talking to people in person you know you
have this experience where you know
you're on my right i'm on your left
right we we kind of have a shared sense
of space and we remember the place that
we were in as is part of how we are
having the conversation and there's all
this stuff all this technology that goes
into delivering this
for example spatial audio right so what
you'll you'll probably notice is you
know when i talk to you it's coming from
your left right
yeah i mean that's that's an important
part of how you know we as people
process the sense of space that we have
and presence in the world is that you
know it's not like in in real life we
have a grid of faces and all the sound
is just coming at us from exactly the
same place but you know we're very
optimistic that
in five years from now
people are going to be able to live
where they want and work from wherever
they want they want but but are going to
be able to feel present as if they're
together when they're doing that do you
have a favorite feature to use in here
yeah something that you think is very
cool
yeah i mean there are a couple of things
that i really like i mean one is that
you can just dynamically change the
layout of the room so you know i mean
here you know i can we're in a a room
layout that's that's designed for
conversation i can switch us really
quickly so now we're um we're in a
presentation setting yes so that's
pretty neat and mike's in the middle
yeah and then you know check this out i
can i can basically go
and um
and and go stand at the white board
and um
wow it's like brainstorming just like in
a normal meeting that you would have
been in so i can say
you know welcome
to workrooms
guys this is so freaking cool but this
is the thing i worry about i miss being
in the office with people i worry i like
what you said mark that people will be
able to work wherever they want to
but but does this mean that we'll be
spending less time in the office
i so miss people am i alone in that
people in the room
i don't think you're alone in that i'm
looking forward to seeing my my
colleagues colleagues and friends too
but um but yeah you're probably a bit
more extroverted than most people if i
had to guess um
certainly more extroverted than me but i
i do just think that going forward um
there are going to be more people who
work remotely so i think that there's
there's an important place for offices
for people to come together but i also
think that there's an important place
for people who may want to live with
their you know stay with their family or
where they grew up but also want to get
access to opportunities that maybe
historically would have only been in in
new york or you know in l.a and you know
i just think that those opportunities
should be available to everyone so you
know all these tools whether it's video
conferencing or you know eventually
being able to
collaborate better in the metaverse in
products like workrooms we built here i
think is is all just part of this
progression of giving people more
freedom to
to live where they want
i saw a presentation years ago steve
jobs said in your phone right now right
now it's just a phone but the day's
going to come when you can play music
you can send emails
you can take pictures
and when i first heard it that just
sounded how in the world can that
possibly be and here it is everybody who
has one in their pocket
is that how you see the metaverse it
will be that ubiquitous that people you
know it will not be a foreign term we'll
all know it we'll all be using it and
we'll think nothing of it is that how
you see it yes and and i think that will
be the case in the next five to ten
years i think we'll have devices that
will will be
um you know like a normal pair of
glasses that you can wear that can put
holograms into the world and i think
we'll just have these amazing and
magical experiences um i think it's
gonna be wild and it's it's the the
thing that i am the most excited um
about contributing to to building um
over the next five to ten years
all right mark zuckerberg okay as we see
to august 2021 you and i have a date
five to seven years from now where we're
gonna play this interview and we're
gonna say mark remember when you told us
fill in the blank i look forward to that
august 2021 five years from now i can't
wait
see did you hear he said he looks
forward to that listen mark zuckerberg
is not like the other kids in the class
and clearly hasn't been for a long time
he told me that when he was in middle
school this is sort of a dream come true
for him he said you know we'd leave his
friends they would go off he said
wouldn't it be great if we had a world
where we could still play together but
be in different places yeah i said you
actually thought about that in middle
school and middle school i thought when
my friend left i go i'll see you
tomorrow because we didn't even have
phones cell phones we didn't have cell
phones
so for him to be thinking about that
even as a little kid and now to be in
one of the forefront one of the leaders
who's you know putting this out in the
universe i i'm fascinated you know
listen i thought this was a little this
is the most attractive thing they got to
work on that it was a little clunky for
me but i could clearly see where with
some lessons i could get it yeah i could
get it yeah i know i'm technically
challenged but i could get that i'm with
you though i miss people in the office
yeah as well
anthony i miss people i don't like
i even miss them
they shall remain nameless but you know
who you are
all right and i'm looking forward to it
no i have to i i do hope the internet
improves so something works everywhere
that's yeah that's highly dependent on
good web access